Welcome to "Five Dangerous Things
You Should Let Your Children Do."
I don't have children.
I borrow my friends' children, so --
(Laughter)
take all this advice with a grain of salt.
I'm Gever Tulley.
I'm a contract computer
scientist by trade,
but I'm the founder of something
called the Tinkering School.
It's a summer program
which aims to help kids
learn how to build the things
that they think of.
So we build a lot of things,
and I do put power tools
into the hands of second-graders.
So if you're thinking about sending
your kid to Tinkering School,
they do come back bruised,
scraped and bloody.
(Laughter)
You know, we live in a world
that's subjected to ever more
stringent child safety regulations.
There doesn't seem to be
any limit on how crazy
child safety regulations can get.
We put suffocation warnings
on every piece of plastic film
manufactured in the United States,
or for sale with an item
in the United States.
We put warnings on coffee cups
to tell us that the contents may be hot.
And we seem to think that any item
sharper than a golf ball is too sharp
for children under the age of 10.
So where does this trend stop?
When we round every corner
and eliminate every sharp object,
every pokey bit in the world,
then the first time that kids
come in contact with anything sharp,
or not made out of round plastic,
they'll hurt themselves with it.
So, as the boundaries
of what we determine as the safety zone
grow ever smaller,
we cut off our children
from valuable opportunities
to learn how to interact
with the world around them.
And despite all of our best
efforts and intentions,
kids are always going to figure out
how to do the most dangerous
thing they can,
in whatever environment they can.
(Laughter)
So despite the provocative title,
this presentation is really about safety,
and about some simple things
that we can do
to raise our kids to be creative,
confident and in control
of the environment around them.
And what I now present to you
is an excerpt from a book in progress.
The book is called "50 Dangerous Things."
This is "Five Dangerous Things."
Thing number one: Play with fire.
Learning to control one of the most
elemental forces in nature
is a pivotal moment
in any child's personal history.
Whether we remember it or not,
it's the first time we really get control
of one of these mysterious things.
These mysteries are only revealed
to those who get the opportunity
to play with it.
So, playing with fire.
This is like one of the great things
we ever discovered, fire.
From playing with it, they learn
some basic principles about fire,
about intake, combustion, exhaust.
These are the three working
elements of fire
that you have to have
for a good, controlled fire.
And you can think of the open-pit
fire as a laboratory.
You don't know what they're going
to learn from playing with it.
Let them fool around with it
on their own terms and trust me,
they're going to learn things
that you can't get out of playing
with Dora the Explorer toys.
(Laughter)
Number two: Own a pocketknife.
Pocketknives are kind of drifting
out of our cultural consciousness,
which I think is a terrible thing.
(Laughter)
Your first pocketknife
is like the first universal tool
that you're given.
You know, it's a spatula, it's a pry bar,
it's a screwdriver and it's a blade, yeah.
And it's a powerful and empowering tool.
And in a lot of cultures
they give knives --
like, as soon as they're
toddlers, they have knives.
These are Inuit children
cutting whale blubber.
I first saw this in a Canadian
Film Board film when I was 10,
and it left a lasting impression,
to see babies playing with knives.
And it shows that kids can develop
an extended sense of self
through a tool at a very young age.
You lay down a couple
of very simple rules --
always cut away from your body,
keep the blade sharp, never force it --
and these are things kids
can understand and practice with.
And yeah, they're going to cut themselves.
I have some terrible scars on my legs
from where I stabbed myself.
But you know, they're young.
They heal fast.
(Laughter)
Number three: Throw a spear.
It turns out that our brains
are actually wired for throwing things,
and like muscles, if you don't
use parts of your brain,
they tend to atrophy over time.
But when you exercise them,
any given muscle adds strength
to the whole system,
and that applies to your brain, too.
So practicing throwing things
has been shown to stimulate
the frontal and parietal lobes,
which have to do with
visual acuity, 3D understanding,
and structural problem solving,
so it helps develop their visualization
skills and their predictive ability.
And throwing is a combination
of analytical and physical skill,
so it's very good for that kind
of whole-body training.
These kinds of target-based practices
also help kids develop
attention and concentration skills,
so those are great.
Number [four]: Deconstruct appliances.
There is a world of interesting things
inside your dishwasher.
Next time you're about
to throw out an appliance,
don't throw it out.
Take it apart with your kid,
or send him to my school,
and we'll take it apart with them.
Even if you don't know what the parts are,
puzzling out what they might be for
is a really good practice for the kids
to get sort of the sense
that they can take things apart,
and no matter how complex they are,
they can understand parts of them.
And that means that eventually,
they can understand all of them.
It's a sense of knowability,
that something is knowable.
So these black boxes that we live with
and take for granted
are actually complex things
made by other people,
and you can understand them.
Number five: Two-parter.
Break the Digital
Millennium Copyright Act.
(Laughter)
There are laws beyond safety regulations
that attempt to limit
how we can interact with the things
that we own -- in this case,
digital media.
It's a very simple exercise:
Buy a song on iTunes, write it to a CD,
then rip the CD to an MP3,
and play it on your very same computer.
You've just broken a law.
Technically, the RIAA
could come and prosecute you.
It's an important lesson
for kids to understand,
that some of these laws
get broken by accident,
and that laws have to be interpreted.
That's something we often
talk about with the kids
when we're fooling around with things
and breaking them open,
and taking them apart
and using them for other things.
And also when we go out and drive a car.
Driving a car is a really empowering act
for a young child,
so this is the alternate --
(Laughter)
For those of you who aren't comfortable
actually breaking the law,
you can drive a car with your child.
This is a great stage for a kid.
This happens about the same time
that they get latched onto
things like dinosaurs,
these big things in the outside world,
that they're trying to get a grip on.
A car is a similar object,
and they can get in a car and drive it.
And that really gives them
a handle on a world
in a way that they don't often
have access to.
And it's perfectly legal.
Find a big empty lot,
make sure there's nothing in it,
and that it's on private property,
and let them drive your car.
It's very safe actually.
And it's fun for the whole family.
(Laughter)
Let's see, I think that's it.
That's number five and a half. OK.